who else again but it's a matter of it's
a better make it interesting
yeah guys we could spend and the type of
ability because how do you think you
should go back
how would you like to come back
I'll take that as a yes hey everybody so
I've been getting a lot of messages from
you guys asking for a Superman Man of
Steel to video because Henry Cavill has
talked about them developing the movie
he was an ace Comic Con a little while
ago saying oh oh yeah we're working on
it right now which is why I put that
clip at the beginning of it like oh yeah
it's just a matter of finding the right
story so they're just looking for that
and they're looking for a director so
then separately Matthew Vaughn who's
been in talks for a Superman movie for a
long time now confirmed that he's
currently talking to DC about a number
of things he says a number of things but
I'll play his interview really quick and
then Mark Millar separately also said
that he collaborated with Matthew Vaughn
about a separate Superman film so I'll
include a clip from that too but it
gives you an idea for what's going on
behind the scenes right now with the
future of that character specifically
that part of the Justice League
everybody else has heard about what's
going on with Wonder Woman flash point
Batman the Matt Reeves movies so I'll
add a couple updates for that at the end
of the video but if you are finding me
for the first time be sure to subscribe
to get everything there is a new round
of that ticket giveaway - it's just for
any movie that you guys want to go to so
I'll name a new winner at the end of
this but here's that Matthew Vaughn in
the Mark Millar interviews I do love the
world of DC and I've been talking to
them about some few things and and I do
think Marvel any Marvel it's more fun
getting involved with people franchises
when they're on the down yes then you
it's easier to make a good film like so
if I got involved with a few the
superhero movies out there which have
been through say disappointing yeah it's
gonna at least you know if I do it okay
or what would be better so when I did
x-men there was a pretty low bar - yeah
extra men 3 no offense was not the
fantastic yeah piece of work so it was
it's much more fun reinventing and
saving something then I'd be more
intimidated doing it you know trying to
do a new guardians from yeah I'll be
like well I don't know if I can make it
any better
yeah that's really interesting never
think of that because obviously you'd
think you know you see everyone wants to
do like the big ones like Batman's like
have a fight you've followed Christopher
Nolan exactly you don't and that's why
well you do but you have to do it
differently yes oh if you're gonna
advise going to do Batman there's no
point doing the Dark Knight yeah because
it's been done to perfection so you have
to think okay if I was doing Batman I go
Christ let's bring out the Adam West's
version because yeah it's got it you've
got to go you've got to give people
something well for me I'm not interested
in in copying somebody else's take on
the genre yeah yeah that's really
interesting I've been like obviously you
were a producer on Fantastic Four never
seen you say that you know apologize no
no no I already do it but no it's not
fine it was it's I think is a fantastic
piece of IP that didn't go well and but
hey ho that's what happens but that
should be the live action incredible
yeah it's so funny to hear and be so
apologetic about Fantastic Four with a
couple of things that he's talking to DC
right now are most likely that Man of
Steel movie along with flashpoint I
wouldn't be surprised if he was in the
running for the flashpoint movie because
they haven't officially locked a
director down and when it comes to the
stable of directors that Warner Brothers
wants to direct a DC movie at some point
he's just near the top of the list he's
really always been up there Zack Snyder
was picked over him to get the Man of
Steel movie originally so he was already
considered good enough to make DC movies
at the time now obviously his style of
moviemaking very different from Zack
Snyder which is interesting because he
said he prefers franchises that are in a
low point just because the bar is much
lower there's less pressure to deliver
something that's the greatest movie to
hit cinema in the last hundred years so
that's why he said that he never went
for another Batman movie everybody
always asked like do you want to do
another Batman movie but he's like no
way I'm gonna follow Christopher Nolan
and that would be impossible and now it
just seems like it's come full circle
you may have actually seen I think I did
a video about Matthew Vaughn talking
about his original Superman movie idea
but that was for the movie that
eventually turned into the first Man of
Steel movie which he also collaborated
on briefly with Mark Boal are there been
a number of different versions of the
Superman movie before Man of Steel came
along
Matthew Vaughn went to him they
collaborated a little bit so I'll play a
little bit of that interview because
he's pretty fascinating to listen to
someone like him talk about what was
going on at the time
a Superman a picture that was it began
at the beginning of time and end but at
the end of time and it was going to be
Superman's story you know his life story
started with a the formation of Carrie
Sloane Krebs and then everything we we
weave back and like you know running to
Superman's death which would be
obviously whenever the stars away it was
essentially that story but I had a
gigantic gigantic trilogy of stories and
amongst all I had Darkseid and
everything it was like do something feel
about like The Godfather for Superman
you know something that starts really
young making Colleoni and then you
eventually see him dies and all that I
wanted to do something that covers
everything and that was everything I
wanted to see about Superman but I never
happens and we did other stuff from
Stan's there's a really fascinating
concept The Godfather trilogy of
Superman movies where you see the
beginning middle and end Michael
Corleone's style but I think the reason
why they probably wouldn't do something
like that is because they've already
explored the idea of the death and
rebirth of Superman through these last
films and so many people reacted
negatively to them killing Superman off
during Batman vs Superman that I think
that that's like a story beat that they
just will not go back to for a long time
so the other funny part of this is that
he says when Matthew Vaughn came to him
and asked him about his idea for a
Superman movie he went to Warner
Brothers Matthew Vaughn did and said
would you be interested in having Mark
Millar come work on this and they said
absolutely not because at the time he
was hardcore Marvel he was working on
the first Civil War comic book so it was
just funny to hear the people of Warner
Brothers were like no no no we don't
want to disrespect the DC people by
bringing in a Marvel guy just hearing
the way their minds worked back then in
the studio system is kind of funny even
given that it's less than 10 years ago
so it just gives you an idea like all
those people that were there at Warner
Brothers at that time have either been
fired or they've moved on so I've
already done a whole bunch of videos
about how things have structurally
changed at Warner Brothers and the
people involved in green lighting in the
business end of making the comic book
movies looks completely different than
it did even just a couple years ago so
just let me know in the comments what do
you think about Matthew Vaughn doing a
new Man of Steel movie or would you
rather see him do the flashpoint movie
because that movie
ready to go I think it'd take at least
two and a half to three years to get it
on screen just because you need about a
year to get the script on then about two
years to go through principal
photography and post-production so it's
gonna be a while before we get out of
there solo Superman film so just like he
says at the beginning of this clip
they're working on it but it's gonna
take a while but that's a good thing
because a lot of the problems with
Justice League were attributed to them
wanting to hit their year-end bonuses
like executives wanting to push the
movie out faster so they could
potentially declare a bigger profit for
the company during 2017 rather than
defer that to 2018 just causing all
kinds of problems with post-production
making it harder for them to make Henry
Cavill face look less uncanny valley so
just in general it sounds like there's
gonna be less meddling with some of the
DC films in the near future but like I
said there is a new round of that ticket
giveaway it's for any movie that you
guys want to go to so all you have to do
to enter that is be a subscriber leave a
DC related comment on the video
congratulations to the winner from my
last video curette e please private
message me so I can get your contact
details I'll name a new winner when I
post new DC there's some new god speed
that I'm working on and there's some new
DC TV that I'll try and get out this
week but click here to learn all about
spider-man homecoming 2 and click here
to learn all about star wars episode 9
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight